1986
the year a legend was born
it's one of the best performing
motorsport models ever
the idol of an entire generation
the first bmw m3
it can go anywhere
dirt road
or race track
the beamer m3 was designed in both
motorsports and road going models
under the hood was an optimized
four-cylinder engine that had already
scored successes for the bmw 1800 ti in
the 1960s
the j-sport company is based in cologne
normally its staff customize toyotas but
managing director gerald boning has a
personal attachment to the early beamer
m3s
what he loves about the m3 is for one
that it's a proper motorsports car and
shows it with its flared fenders and it
was the last car built for both purposes
nowadays all he sees is wannabe racing
cars or actual racing cars that only
vaguely resemble a production car
that's the attraction of the m3 it's
just as suitable for doing your shopping
on saturday as for driving a few laps on
the nurburgring these hours come
the earliest m3s were quite easy going
on regular roads its 215 horsepower
engine enabled top speeds of 245
kilometers an hour in the 1980s it
practically had the fast lane to itself
gerald bonango has a 1987 m3 in very
good condition
he describes it as a chicato replica dtm
car
johnny chacotto was also a grand prix
motorcycle champion and he's most
impressed that someone could race both
motorcycles and cars
the venezuelan star's first german
touring car's victory was in 1989 in an
m3
between 1987 and 1992 the m3 won two
european touring car championships two
german titles and several other
international competitions over 1500
victories with more than 50 championship
titles in seven years made the beamer m3
the world's top touring car
nowadays an m3 in pristine condition can
be had for around 30 000 euros the
engine may not have the best pickup at
lower revs but on the racetrack it more
than holds its own on city streets too
it's a faithful workhorse
the bmw m3 legend on the road and
racetrack